in solidar the battle is relentless
the once thriving salt mining town in
eastern Ukraine is now A Wasteland after
months of fighting between Ukrainian and
Russian forces supported by mercenaries
from the Russian Wagner group its head
yefgeni pregojin posted a photo of
himself and his troops online saying
they've taken control of Soledad
Wagner units have taken control of the
entire territory of Soledad a cauldron
has been formed in the center of the
city in which urban fighting is going on
a spokesperson for Russia's defense
ministry didn't comment on the claims
but said that Russian Airborne units had
surrounded the town securing it would
help Russian forces in their push to
capture the entire donbass region but
Ukrainian military officials and some
soldiers on the ground say solidar has
not fallen and that Ukrainian forces are
holding on
all our positions are still holding from
time to time there's close combat and
artillery fire on both sides
Ukraine's President also dismissed
Russian claims
no the terrorist state and its
propagandists are strive to pretend that
some part of our city of Soledad almost
completely destroyed by the occupiers is
some kind of achievement of Russia they
will present and are already presenting
this to their society in order to
support mobilization and to give hope to
those who are for aggression but the
fighting continues the Donetsk front is
holding
[Music]
earlier zielinski was in the western
city of leviv to pay his respects to
soldiers who've died in the conflict he
also met the Lithuanian president and
Polish president Andre Duda who said
Poland would send leopard tanks to Kiev
as part of an International Coalition to
help Ukraine kivas long said that among
the heavy weapons that it needs tanks
are essential but Western Powers have
been reluctant to send offensive weapons
that could be regarded by Moscow as a
sign of escalating the conflict but the
tide is turning
France has pledged heavy armored
vehicles and the UK is considering
sending its Challenger two tanks some
European countries are increasing
pressure on Germany to do the same
tanks alone clearly can't change the
war's Direction but they'll certainly
help bolster Ukrainian forces in the
face of moscow's ongoing Firepower
Natasha Butler and Jazeera Kiev